Étienne Clin. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Moi, je
m'appelle Étienne Clin. Euh, je suis
physicien au commissariat à l'énergie
atomique et aux énergies alternatives et
je mène depuis assez longtemps euh un
travail de vulgarisation de la physique.
On est très content de vous recevoir
aujourd'hui parce que
c'est notre petit cadeau de Noël. C'est
vous avez été réclamé ardemment par
notre communauté. Donc, c'est pour ça
que on vous a fait revenir avec votre
accord et et voilà, on voulait vous le
vous le dire.
Je témoigne que je suis pas venu de
force.
Première question, qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce scarabé ?
Alors, ce scarabé, beaucoup de gens
pensent que c'est un clin d'œil à Cédric
Vilani, ce qui n'est pas faux. lui porte
une araignée, c'est un ami et en effet,
il y a une forme d'inspiration mutuelle
qui a joué là-dedans. Mais il y a une
autre raison qui est plus fondamentale,
c'est que Einstein, comme vous le savez,
a eu deux fils et le second alors qu'il
avait 12 ans, a demandé à son père,
"Papa, pourquoi es-tu célèbre ?"
Et Einstein a répondu à son fils :
"Quand un scarabé aveugle marche sur une
feuille, il ne peut pas voir que cette
feuille est courbée. Et moi, Einstein,
ton père, j'ai compris ce que le scarabé
aveugle ne peut pas voir à savoir la
courbure de l'espace."
Deuxème question. Qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette équation sur ce gilet ?
Al, ça c'est un gilet auquel je tiens
beaucoup. Il a au moins 25 ans. Il a été
fait par une amie. C'est l'équation de
Schroninger qui est l'équation
comme le chat,
celle qui a engendré le chat. Mais c'est
pas l'équation du chat. Enfin, c'est
l'équation qui rend le chat possible,
disons.
Donc c'est l'équation de Schrodinger
dépendante du temps que Erwin
Schrodinger a écrite pendant les
vacances de Noël de 1925
dans une station de sport d'hiver dans
les grisons qui s'appelle Arosa où il
était parti avec l'une de ses maîtresses
dont l'identité n'a jamais été vraiment
identifiée, n'a jamais été vraiment
éclaircie en tout cas avec
l'autorisation de sa femme. Et cette
équation qui est l'équation vraiment
fondamentale de la mécanique quantique
non relativiste a été, comme il l'a
écrit à l'un de ses amis, découverte par
Schrunninger à l'issue, je le cite, d'un
épisode érotique, fulgurant et tardif.
On sait pas très bien ce que ça veut
dire mais on regrette qu'il ne l'it pas
remercié dans le l'article qu'il a écrit
à cette occasion et qui a été le le
déclenchement de de du formalisme
mathématique de la physique quantique.
J'ai j'ai une autre question. À quoi tu
réfléchis en ce moment ?
En ce moment, à quoi je réfléchis ? Et
bien, je réfléchis à une phrase que m'a
dite Axel Can il y a quelques mois. Euh
je le connaissais et je l'ai croisé dans
la rue euh quelques jours seulement
après qu'il apprenne que la maladie dont
il était atteint était euh à
[grognement] un stade très avancé au
point que il était condamné par la
médecine et il ne le savait pas. Il
était malade mais ça ne se voyait pas.
Il faisait tous ses déplacements en
marchant dans Paris très vite. Il
marchait à 6 km/h.
J'ai marché avec lui pendant 1 heure.
Donc j'ai fait si mes calculs sont b 6
km. et on a parlé de la mise en scène de
la science et de la recherche pendant la
crise sanitaire que nous traversons. Et
il était assez inquiet et à la fin de
notre discussion, il m'a dit "Étienne,
nous les scientifiques, on a foiré."
Et la question que je me pose et à
laquelle je réfléchis, c'est est-ce
qu'il avait raison ? C'est-à-dire est-ce
que il y a pas des leçons à tirer de ces
mois, même bientôt années ? que nous
avons euh traversé avec ce virus. Est-ce
que
les scientifiques n'ont pas raté
l'exercice de pédagogie qu'ils étaient
invités à faire ? Et ça me fait
réfléchir parce qu'en effet euh et je
pense que les gens qui nous écoutent le
savent, moi j'ai toujours été un
militant de la vulgarisation. Je
revendique le terme vulgarisation plutôt
que médiation qui est le terme qui
semble s'imposer aujourd'hui
[grognement] qui laisse entendre que les
vulgarisateurs serait des médiateurs un
peu comme il y a des médiateurs au GIGN.
On en est pas là, il y a pas de prise
d'otage négociateur.
Mais négociateur, non. Par contre euh
moi j'avais l'impression avant que la
vigualisation [raclement de gorge]
ça marche. Ça marche parce que on voit
bien que les livres qu'on peut écrire ou
les conférences qu'on peut donner
suscident des vocations. Des années
après, il y a des étudiants ou des gens
qui sont rentrés dans la recherche qui
disent que c'est après avoir lu tel
livre que j'ai décidé de devenir
chercheur ou scientifique.
[raclement de gorge] Donc on a
l'impression que ça marche. D'autre pas,
quand on écrit des livres, des gens les
lisent, posent des questions
intéressantes ou bien quand on donne des
conférences, les gens viennent et posent
des questions intéressante. Donc on a
l'impression que ça marche très bien.
Mais en réalité quand on dit cela, on
est victime d'un biais énorme qui est un
biais de confirmation. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait la vulgarisation
ne touche que les personnes intéressées
par la vulgarisation. Et ce que m'a
montré la crise, c'est que cette
proportion est assez faible.
Et d'autre part, on il y a un autre
biais qu'on pourrait appeler le un biais
du survivant.
On ne touche que des gens qui n'ont pas
été traumatisé pendant les années
scolaires par leur premier rapport avec
la science. Il y a des gens qui ont
acquis l'idée qui que la science était
pas pour eux. Ils ont été traumatisés
par une mauvaise note ou par un une
remarque faite ici ou là. Ça les marque
à vie.
Du sexisme en général.
Mais pas seulement. Ça se trouve aussi
euh ça se trouve dans les deux sexes en
tout cas et c'est des gens qui euh
estiment qu'ils ne sont pas câblés pour
la science et donc ils ont un rapport
très distancié, très méfiant euh et
c'est très difficile de trouver les
moyens de transpercer cette cette paroie
de verre qui est qui est vraiment
vraiment présente
dans beaucoup de d'esprit si j'ose dire.
Et puis euh moi ma technique pour faire
de la vigorisation c'est assez simple.
c'était de prendre un sujet euh qui me
passionnait évidemment comme par exemple
la physique quantique
ou bien la question du temps en physique
de travailler travailler travailler et
j'ai commencé moi avec l'aide d'un grand
physicien qui s'appelle Bernard Espagia
qui est mort il y a quelques années à
l'âge de 91 ans mais qui m'a formé
comprendre qu'est-ce que c'est que la
mécanique quantique quelles sont ses
équations
quel type de problème permet-elle de
résoudre pour résoudre quel type de
problème sont-elles apparues ? Qui sont
les pers fondateurs qui ont mis sur pied
ce formalisme révolutionnaire dans les
années 1920 ? Qu'est-ce que la physique
quantique permet de penser de la réalité
? Et qu'est-ce qu'elle empêche ou plutôt
qu'est-ce qu'elle
qu'est-ce qu'elle n'empêche qu'est-ce
qu'elle empêche de de croire ? Qu'est-ce
qu'elle permet de penser et qu'est-ce
qu'elle empêche de croire sur la nature
de la réalité ? Donc c'est une physique
qui a des implications philosophiques
importantes et tout ça est passionnant.
Et une fois qu'on a fait tout ce travail
d'inculturation
de la physique quanti antique, on se
sent capable à tort ou à raison d'en
parler à n'importe qui, [grognement] à
des collégiens, à des lycéens, à des
étudiants, à des personnes qui n'ont
jamais fait d'études en adaptant
évidemment son discours aux personnes à
qui on s'adresse
en trouvant des stratagèmes et cetera
comme je l'ai fait pour vous il y a
quelques mois pour
Oui.
pour expliquer le boson de X et il faut
du temps. Il faut du temps. On peut pas
expliquer le boson de X en 3 minutes. Ou
alors on dit des choses qui ressemblent
à des arguments d'autorité et on ne
montre pas comment cette découverte
correspond à une véritable connaissance
parce qu'on ne sait pas dire de quelle
connaissance il s'agit. Bon et donc
j'avais cette cette impression et j'ai
découvert que c'était une illusion.
C'est-à-dire que ce qui a montré la mise
en scène de la science et de la
recherche pendant le Covid, c'est qu'en
réalité, il y a toutes sortes de biais
cognitifs qui interviennent entre
l'émission d'un message scientifique et
sa réception et qui font qu'à la fin le
message peut être complètement
transformé, parfois carrément transformé
en son contraire et ça me fait réfléchir
sur la bonne façon de faire. Autrement
dit, quand Axel Cann dit "Nous les
scientifiques, on a foiré", c'est sans
doute vrai. La question est comment
faire pour ne plus foirer ? Voilà, c'est
à ça que je réfléchis. Et
alors, est-ce que j'ai une piste ? Euh
avant de savoir ce qu'il faudrait faire,
je pense qu'il faut comprendre ce qui
s'est passé. Euh moi, il y a des choses
qui m'ont qui m'ont vraiment frappé euh
sur cette façon qu'on a eu de mettre en
scène la science et la recherche. Euh il
y a d'ailleurs une étude qui vient de
paraître euh publiée dans un rapport
dirigé par Daniel Cohen, l'économiste,
qui montre qu'en France, et c'est une
étude qui concerne tous les pays
européens, mais en France la confiance
dans la parole des scientifiques a
chuté. On a perdu 20 points en quelques
mois alors que le niveau de départ était
à peu près le même dans tous les pays
européens, en Allemagne, en Italie, en
Angleterre, en Belgique, en Espagne.
Très élevé d'ailleurs, grande confiance
dans la parole des scientifiques 90 %.
En France, on a perdu 20 points. Dans
les autres pays, il y a une certaine
stabilité, parfois même une augmentation
de la confiance. Et donc il faut se
demander, moi j'ai pas fait d'études
comparatives, j'ai pas fait des
d'enquête sociologiques, je n'ai pas
comparé les différents systèmes
médiatique entre l'Allemagne, si
l'Allemagne, je suis allé en Allemagne
en juillet 2020 et j'ai assisté à une
conférence de presse d'Angela Merkel qui
parlait donc à la télévision à tous les
Allemands et elle était sans tableau,
sans être accompagnée par un expert ou
un ministre. Elle a donné des cours,
des cours de sciences aux Allemands.
Elle leur a expliqué ce qui est une
exponentielle en y prenant le temps. Et
puis quand elle parlait des
scientifiques, elle disait "Les
scientifiques m'ont dit".
Elle ne disait pas professeur machin ou
professeur bidule, les scientifiques. Et
donc elle faisait intervenir dans son
argumentation une communauté, un nous,
pas un jeu. Il me semble qu'en France,
au contraire, on a beaucoup personnalisé
les discussions. On avait une occasion
en fait historique de faire de la
pédagogie puisque les gens étaient
inquiets, intéressés, voulaient
comprendre, voulait savoir, était
désireux d'avoir des informations et
donc on aurait pu expliquer jour après
jour en temps réel
par exemple
les différentes méthodologies de la
science et on sait qu'elles ne sont pas
les mêmes selon les différentes
sciences. un physicien thoricien ne
travaille pas comme un sociologue, qui
ne travaille pas comme un médecin, qui
ne travaille pas comme un chercheur en
biologie. Donc faut expliquer. Et puis
on aurait pu par exemple prendre du
temps pour expliquer ce qu'est
s'agissant de traitement. Par exemple,
un essai en double aveugle, un essai
randomisé.
Pourquoi la théorie des probabilités est
parfois contreintuitive ? Pourquoi il ne
faut pas confondre
coïncidence, corrélation, causalité ?
pas parce que il y a des grenouilles
après la pluie qu'on a raison de dire
qu'il a plus les grenouilles. Et puis on
aurait pu vraiment expliquer tout ça et
au lieu il me semble il me semble qu'au
lieu de faire cette pédagogie qui à mon
avis aurait intéressé les gens,
on a préféré organiser des jutes, des
controverses, des clashes entre
personnalités dont on connaissait à
l'avance les opinions et il me semble
que ça a participé de la de la confusion
générale.
On se dit mais si les experts ne sont
pas d'accord, pourquoi moi avec mon
ressenti, mon bon sens, mes croyances,
mes connaissances, je ne serais pas en
droit de dire ce qu'il faut penser de
tel ou tel sujet qui apparemment fait
controverse ? Et puis une autre chose
qui m'a frappé, c'est qu'on a confondu
en beaucoup de situations la science et
la recherche
qui évidemment la science et la
recherche sont pas deux activités
étrangères l'une à l'autre, mais elles
ne se confondent pas.
ce qu'on appelle la science, en tout cas
ce que j'appelle la science, il me
semble que tout le monde sera d'accord,
c'est un corpus de connaissance bien
établi qui sont, pense-on, les bonnes
réponses à des questions bien posées.
C'est pas des vérités absolues, c'est
pas des vérités définitives, mais on ne
peut les contester que si on a des
arguments scientifiques. On peut pas les
contester avec son bon sens. Moi, je
pense que c'est pas un argument
suffisant. Par exemple, la question de
la forme de la Terre a été tranchée.
Elle n'est pas plate, elle est plutôt
ronde, mais elle est pas sphérique.
La question, est-ce que l'atome existe ?
question qui a été posée pendant 2
million et demi.
Elle a été tranchée en 1906 quand
Jean-Périn a montré expérimentalement
que l'atome existe. Donc cette question
qui a été débattue pendant des
millénaires a été tranchée. L'affaire
est réglée, l'atome existe. Ensuite par
exemple, est-ce que les espèces vivantes
évoluent ?
Ou évoluent. C'est réglé. Est-ce que
l'univers observable est en expansion ?
C'est réglé. Est-ce que les ondes
gravitationales existent ? C'est réglé.
Bon, donc on voit que il y a des
connaissances qu'on a du mal à contesté.
Mais évidemment ce corpus qui constitue
la science, il est par essence
incomplet.
Par construction, il est incomplet.
C'est-à-dire que ces connaissances parce
qu'elles ne sont pas complètes, posent
des questions dont nous ne connaissons
pas les réponse. Et c'est pour cela
qu'on fait de la recherche. Par exemple,
l'atome existe mais il y a des
particules élémentaires que nous
connaissons. Par exemple, les neutrinos
dont nous ne savons pas dire si elles
sont identiques ou non à leur
antiparticule.
Donc nous faisons des recherches.
Est-ce que il existe une vie
extraterrestre ? On nen sait rien, on
fait des recherches. Donc il suffit que
je donne ces exemples pour qu'on
comprenne que le doute, le doute le fait
de savoir qu'on ne sait pas, ce qui est
pas la même chose d'ignorer.
Tout ce que je sais, c'est que je ne
sais rien.
Oui, mais il y a des choses que je sais
quand même. On sait ce qu'on sait et on
sait ce qu'on ne sait pas. Et la
recherche est donc activée par le doute.
Donc le doute, c'est le moteur de la
recherche et en même temps c'est son
combustible parce que à mesure qu'on a
des résultats, le doute se déplace. Et
quand on confond la science et la
recherche comme on l'a beaucoup fait, le
doute qui est consubstantiel à la
recherche vient coloniser l'idée même de
science. Et on présente la science comme
étant le lieu permanent du doute. Mais
c'est pas vrai. Moi, je connais pas de
physicien qui doute de l'ence de
l'atome. Euh je connais pas de
d'astrophysicien qui doute de
l'expansion de l'univers. Et donc là, il
y a peut-être un travail pédagogique à
faire, je sais pas comment, pour que
cette confusion n'ait plus lieu. Et je
pense que alors vous me demandiez c'est
quoi la piste, c'est quoi la solution ?
Moi, j'en ai pas comme ça. Il il y a
deux propositions qu'on peut élaborer.
La première, c'est de dire quand un
scientifique parle
publiquement, surtout en situation de
crise, il devrait dire "Nous savons que
c'est pas moi qui pense que c'est nous.
On a discuté ensemble, on a travaillé
ensemble et nous avons convenu que tel
résultat permettait de dire qu'on a fait
parler un bout du réal." Donc nous
sommes d'accord pour dire que nous
savons ceci. Ça c'est la science. Et
nous demandons si nous nous demandons si
ça c'est la deuxième partie de la phrase
qui concerne la recherche les questions
qu'on se pose. Voilà. Et j'ai trouvé moi
que les
personnes qui étaient invitées dans
certains médias au début de l'épidémie à
beaucoup de questions qui étaient posées
par les journalistes répondaient je ne
sais pas ou nous ne savons pas. Et quand
on répond à trois questions successives
nous ne savons pas il y a toute chance
qu'on ne soit pas réinvité. une nouvelle
fois. On veut des gens qui qui non pas
qui savent forcément mais qui disent
qu'ils savent et on donne ainsi une
prime à ceux qui parlent avec le plus
d'arrogance parfois au-delà de leur
connaissance et pratiquent ce qu'on
appelle d'un terme un peu un peu savant
et sans doute maladroit, l'ultra
crépidarianisme
qui consiste à parler au-delà de ses
compétences. Je fais juste un clin d'œil
à ma mère parce que elle écoute et c'est
un private joke. Tu es en
Bonjour madame,
qu'est-ce que tu dois faire ?
Bah on va parler Est-ce que tu veux
parler des ondes gravitationnelles ?
Les ondes gravitationnelles ? Bah j'aime
pas en parler en 5 minutes, mais
je reviendrai pour en parler plus
longuement comme j'avais fait pour le
bon X. Alors, on mettra le tableau.
Mais ce qui est extraordinaire dans les
zones gravitationnelles, c'est la
jeunesse de l'idée.
Vous savez quand Einstein en 1907, il
est encore au bureau des brevets à
Berne. C'est 2 ans après l'année
miraculeuse, l'année où il a écrit cinq
articles sur cinq sujets différents qui
dans chaque domaine qu'il aborde apporte
la révolution. les l'hypothèse des
cantats lumineux, la relativité
restreinte, E= MC2, euh l'effet
photoélectrique et cetera. Bon, et 2 ans
plus tard, il est toujours dans son
bureau des brevets. Il a un tabouret,
euh donc il a pas de dossier et en
rentrant déjeuner, il fait toujours une
sorte de sieste semiéveillée.
Donc il se repose, il ferme les yeux et
dès qu'il s'endort trop, bah il y a un
réflexe de son corps qui le réveille.
Donc son truc c'est de trouver des idées
et d'avoir suffisamment d'attention pour
pouvoir les capter
lorsqu'elles surviennent. Et il
racontera plus tard que un jour de
novembre 1907, il a eu l'idée la plus
heureuse de sa vie. Il ajoute cette idée
a provoqué en moi une très forte émotion
qui m'a mené 7 ans plus tard vers une
nouvelle théorie de la gravitation.
Alors c'est quoi cette idée ? Mais il le
dit. J'ai compris ce jour-là qu'une
personne en chute libre ne sent pas son
propre poids.
Incroyable. C'est pas du tout une
découverte.
C'est un peu comme les politiques non ?
Quand ils tombent.
Non non, pas faire d'allusion de même si
sans doute que ce que vous dites là est
vrai, mais
en fait il a simplement mis en scène son
corps dans une expérience de pensée
et il a finalement fait parler les
équations de Newton. de Galilée sur la
chute des corps. Galilée a dit tous les
corps tombent à la même vitesse.
C'est une vieille histoire. 3 siècles
plus tôt en 1604 tous les corps tombent
à la même vitesse. Mais ce que comprend
Einstein V = 1 de GT carré, c'est ça non
? Oui. En fait, la vitesse de chute dit
Galilée, elle est proportionnelle à la
durée de la chute. Donc un corps, quelle
que soit sa nature, quelle que soit sa
masse, qui tombe depuis 2 secondes, va
deux fois plus vite qu'un corps qui
tombe depuis une seconde. Et un corps
qui tombe depuis 10 secondes va 10 fois
plus vite qu'un corps qui tombe depuis
une seconde. C'est ça la loi de la chute
des corps de Galilée. Et
Einstein comprend ou plutôt ressent, il
dira plus tard qu'il a une pensée
musculaire. Il a mis son corps en
situation en imaginant ce que ce qu'on
ce que son corps ressentirait
s'il était placé dans une situation
physique qu'il pouvait imaginer mais pas
réaliser. Enfin, on peut toujours se
jeter dans le vide mais c'est pas
recommandé. Et et il a donc compris que
quand tu tombes en chute libre, les
objets qui tombent avec toi tombent à la
même vitesse que toi parce que tous les
corps tombent à la même vitesse.
80 m second.
Voilà. Et donc si je prends ce micro et
je le lâche pendant ma chute, non, je
vais pas le lâcher mais si je le
lâchais,
je verrais qu'il tombe à la mitesse que
moi. Donc par rapport à moi, il ne tombe
pas. Incroyable. C'estàd que le fait de
subir la gravitation
fait disparaître le poids. Tout se passe
comme si on avait plus de poids quand on
est en train de tomber. Autrement dit,
la chute des corps, la chute des corps
euh met la gravitation hors du
spectacle.
Ce qui est très fort, c'est que
l'anagramme de la chute des corps, c'est
hors du spectacle. Bon et et cette idée
va le bouleverser.
et il va euh énoncer ce qu'on appelle le
principe d'équivalence qui va le mener 8
ans plus tard vers une nouvelle théorie
de la gravitation, la relativité
générale d'Instein qu'il publie en
novembre 1915. Et dès le dès le mois de
janvier 1916,
il prédit en hésitant un peu l'existence
des ondes gravitationnelles qui sont des
ondes qui se propagent dans
l'espace-temps à la vitesse de la
lumière et modifient sur leur passage
les distances entre les points de
l'espace. Et c'est ces ondes qui ont été
détectées pour la première fois. Enfin,
elles ont traversé la Terre en 1900 en
en septembre 2015 et l'analyse a permis
de de les de les reconnaître et
d'annoncer la première détection d'onde
gravitationnelle en 2016, ce qui a donné
lieu à un prix Nobel quelques années
plus tard.
Vous parliez d'expérience de pensée.
Est-ce que vous avez pas l'impression
qu'en France, on s'interdit ça
maintenant ? on on
rechigne à laisser ce c son cerveau
divaguer.
Alors l'expérience de pensée c'est la
clé. C'estd que la physique moderne est
née grâce à des expériences de pensée
pas grâce à des données.
Mais c'est pas le délire. L'expérience
de pensée, c'est un alliage entre la
raison et l'imagination. Il s'agit euh
de demander à la réalité plutôt aux
théories physiques, aux lois physiques
d'aller se faire se faire voir ailleurs
pour voir ce qu'elles ont dans le fond
dans le ventre. Il s'agit de tester leur
leur consistance. Il s'agit de faire un
pas de côté
pour faire en sorte que le monde le
monde empirique décoïcide
d'avec ce qu'il semble nous montrer
d'une façon trop convaincante.
Et en l'occurrence pour la chute des
corps, Galilée a fait une espèce de
pensée parce que à l'époque on savait
pas faire le vide. Non seulement on
savait pas le faire mais la plupart des
savants des doctes expliquaient que le
vide ne pouvait pas exister au motif que
la nature a horreur du vide. Mais
Galilée, il s'occupe pas de savoir si le
vide existe ou pas. En tout cas, pas à
cette époque-là. Il utilise le vide
comme un milieu de pensée idéal au sein
duquel il y a pas de résistance au
mouvement. Et il a l'intuition géniale
que dans ce milieu, les lois du
mouvement se montreraient de façon plus
simple, de façon même tellement simple
qu'on pourrait les mathématiser.
Le problème c'est que il peut pas faire
le vide. Comment est-ce qu'il peut
montrer qu'il a raison ? Mais il le fait
en inventant une expérience de pensée
qui est racontée par son porte-parole
qui s'appelle Salviati dans son livre
Discours sur deux sciences nouvelles.
Alors qu'est-ce qu'il dit ? C'est c'est
un texte absolument génial, il faut le
lire.
Aristote qui faisait autorité à l'époque
dit un corps tombe d'autant plus vite
qu'il est plus massif.
Donc plus un corps est lourd, plus il
tombe vite. Ce qui ressemble un peu à ce
qu'on voit. Une
une grosse pierre tombe plus vite qu'une
petite pierre.
Et donc Galilée dit "Supposons
qu'Aristote a raison."
Et c'est maintenant que commence
l'expérience de pensée. Prenons une
grosse pierre et une petite pierre.
Relions-les l'une à l'autre par une
ficelle.
On fait une expérience de pensée
puisqu'on dit si on les relie par une
ficelle. qui est au départ, on se met
ailleurs que là où on est. Si on les
relie l'une à l'autre par une ficelle,
que va-t-il se passer si on laisse
tomber l'ensemble
d'une certaine hauteur ? Que dit
Aristote ? Aristote dit "L'ensemble
formé par les deux pierres est plus
lourd que la grosse pierre. Donc
l'ensemble va tomber plus vite que la
grosse pierre toute seule. Mais en même
temps, pendant la chute,
la petite pierre qui tombe moins vite va
tendre la corde.
Elle va donc jouer le rôle d'un
parachute qui va freiner la chute de la
grosse pierre. Donc la même loi
d'Aristote explique que l'ensemble va
tomber plus vite que la grosse pierre et
moins vite que la grosse pierre.
Contradiction.
Galilée invente une expérience qui
montre qu' une contradiction interne
dans la loi d'Aristote. Comment résoudre
la contradiction ?
en disant que la grosse pierre tombe
exactement à la même vitesse que la
petite pierre, ce qui n'est pas ce que
nous voyons dans la vie quotidienne.
Et après, il y a toute la question :
comment une loi qui contredit
l'observation, celle de Galilée,
peut-elle expliquer l'observation
en disant que il y a une force qui est
la gravitation qui fait tomber tous les
corps de la même façon et puis il y a
d'autres forces liées à la présence d'un
milieu en l'occurrence l'air qui sont
responsables
du fait que tous les objets que nous
voyons tomber ne tombent pas à la même
vitesse. et la résistance de l'air, il y
a la poussée d'Archimède, mais on doit
pas mettre sur le compte de la
gravitation des effets qui viennent
d'autres force que la gravitation.
J'ai envie de vous poser une question.
À quoi vous rêvez ? C'est que est-ce que
vous avez trois rêves par exemple à
exaucer avant la fin la fin de votre vie
?
Ah ben je vais commencer par un rêve que
j'ai longtemps fait mais que je ne fais
plus parce que j'ai fait l'expérience
correspondant au vert au rêve pardon au
vert.
Non, c'est tout simple. Moi,
[raclement de gorge] j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être astronaute.
Euh j'ai été même candidat en 1996 quand
le Kness a essayé de de recruter des
astronautes.
C'est l'année de Patrick Bauder non ?
Ou l'année de Claudieur
mais moi j'avais des problèmes
d'oreilles qui ont fait que j'étais tout
de suite éliminé.
Euh mais j'ai toujours eu ce rêve et
j'ai rêvé.
Pourquoi ?
J'ai rêvé d'être en imposanteur. Voilà.
J'ai marmari
et puis et puis un jour, j'ai vraiment
fait le rêve que j'étais dans une
capsule spatiale et j'ai fait un rêve où
j'étais en imposanteur
et et ce rêve a été tellement
merveilleux que ça m'a un peu guéri de
l'envie. C'est j' l'impression d'y avoir
été réellement. Et puis au mois de mai
dernier, en 2021, j'apprends que
l'observateur de l'espace qui dépend du
KNES lance un appel à projet pour les
sciences humaines et sociales, ce qu'on
appelle une résidence en impesanteur.
Et je je rédige un projet tout de suite
dans la nuit que j'envoie au Kness et
j'ai été pris. Et le projet est très
simple, c'est de dire quand eu l'idée
que je viens de de raconter, quand je
tombe, je ne sens pas mon poids.
Einstein dit dans une dans une en 1945,
il y a un français qui s'appelle Jacques
Adamar qui était mathématicien qui s'est
réfugié à New York et qui a questionné
tous les mathématiciens et tous les
physiciens théoriens qu'il connaissaient
pour leur demander comment vous viennent
vos idées, quel est le rôle du langage
dans l'élaboration de vos idées ? Et
Einstein entend parler de ce travail de
cette enquête et répond il faut lire ses
réponses. C'est absolument génial. Il
dit il dit "Ah ben j'ai dans un livre,
je les ai rapporté.
Quel livre ?
Euh
le pays qui habitait Alber le pays qui
habitait Albert Einstein. Il dit
"J'avais une pensée musculaire.
Mes idées s'exprimaient sous une forme
mentale qui qui ne s'appuyait pas sur le
langage. Et tout le travail ensuite
c'était de traduire en mots ce que ces
images véhiculaient comme idée. Moi,
j'ai écrit au KNES, bah je veux faire
une expérience de vol en imposanteur.
C'est les vols 0G. Vous savez, c'est un
Airbus à 310, on fait des paraboles
à Toulouse.
Voilà. À Bordeaux.
à Bordeaux et on décolle, on l'avion
monte avec une une accélération très
forte à 45°gr, coupe les moteurs, on
tombe puis on fait ça 40 fois de suite
et pendant 20 secondes durée de la
chute, on est en impesanteur. Et j'ai
dit dans mon projet, j'ai dit bah voilà,
je vais essayer de mettre des mots
dans cette expérience de pensée d'chail
en réalisant l'expérience vraiment.
Qu'est-ce qu'on ressent quand on est en
chute libre ? Qu'est-ce qu'on ressent
quand il y a plus de pesanteur ? Et
évidemment, on ressent pas son poids. Ça
c'est vérifié. Mais la question que je
me posais moi, c'est quand on sent pas
son poids,
quel est le plaisir ?
Alors attendez, quand on sent pas son
poids, comment est-ce qu'on sent son
corps ? Autrement dit, quel est le rôle
que joue la gravitation dans la
perception que nous avons dans notre
corps ? Alors, d'abord dans les périodes
de chute libre de 20 secondes, il y a
une sorte de sérénité incroyable. Tous
les mouvements, tous les mens sont doux.
la dynamique est ralentie, on met du
temps à comprendre parce que on vit le
principe, on vit le principe d'inertie,
hein, une petite pichenette et puis donc
on a des mouvements trop violents parce
que dans la vie courante, on a intégré
la gravitation dans sa façon d'anticiper
les effets de nos mouvements. Et là,
non. D'ailleurs, je pense que quand il y
a des réunions très houleuses,
on devrait les faire en impesanteur. Si
quelqu'un nous dit quelque chose qui
nous déplaît, une petite bichennette et
il part en ligne droite, quoi. On voit
le on voit le principe d'inertie
s'actualiser. C'est assez assez doux en
fait et ça crée entre les personnes qui
sont là, en était une vingtaine, une
certaine harmonie spontanée, hein. Et
puis dans les phases d'hypergravité,
quand l'avion accélère pour prendre de
l'altitude, là on est on a de ou 3 G, je
sais plus. Là on sent vraiment son
corps. Par exemple, si vous levez le
bras comme ça, ben il pèse deux ou trois
fois son son poids normal, si j'ose
dire. Et c'est comme si vous faisiez de
la musculation sans artère, sans altère
sans altère. Vous le voulez vous levez
les bras.
Donc moi, j'ai passé toutes ces ces
phases de monté à faire des exercices
physiques, des pompes. Alors les pompes,
c'est
des abdominaux surtout.
Voilà. Et et c'est du sport. C'est du
sport. Donc j'ai j'ai vécu ce rêve qui a
coupé mon histoire psychique en deux.
D'ailleurs, il y a une question alors
que j'ai pas pu résoudre parce que là
l'expérience était trop courte mais j'ai
envoyé une lettre à Thomas Pesquet pour
lui poser cette question. J'ai pas
trouvé la réponse dans toutes les études
bibliographiques que j'ai pu faire.
Quand vous êtes en imposanteur pendant
des mois, comme ça a été son cas, euh
est-ce que dans les rêves que vous
faites, [grognement]
vous êtes en imposanteur ou est-ce que
dans les rêves, vous continuez d'être
sur terre dans le champ de gravité
terrestre ? Et si vous finissez par
rêver que vous êtes en impesanteur, au
bout au bout de combien de temps ces
rêves deviennent possibles ? Ce qui est
une façon indirecte de poser la question
de savoir si la gravitation est
engrammée dans notre inconscient, dans
notre psyché. Est-ce qu'elle est
engrammée ou est-ce que en vivant
longtemps en imposanteur, on pourrait
finalement faire comme si elle
n'existait pas ? Et une autre question,
c'est celle du langage.
Le langage, il s'est formé, je sais pas
trop comment, mais en tout cas, il a été
inventé par des gens qui étaient dans le
champ de gravité terrestre. Et la
gravité, elle polarise notre rapport à
l'espace.
Ex quand vous faites de l'alpinisme, ce
qui m'arrive,
comment est-ce que les alpinistes
appellent ce qui est en dessous d'eux ?
Ils appellent ça le vide.
Mais en fait le vide, il est au-dessus
d'eux. Autrement dit, ils appellent vide
ceux dans quoi ils peuvent tomber. Donc
la gravitation polarise leur rapport à
l'espace en en en montrant que la
verticale n'est pas la même selon qu'on
la regarde en bas ou selon qu'on la
regarde en haut. En fait, quand vous
êtes à 5000 m d'altitude, il y a moins
de matière entre vous et la lune qu'il y
a de matière entre vous et le niveau de
la mer. D'accord ? Donc tout tout
notre langage, il est il est influencé
de façon implicite par le fait que nous
vivons dans un champ de gravité et et si
on avait vécu en imposanteur, est-ce
qu'on parlerait de la même façon de
l'espace ?
Répondu il a répondu Thomas ? Non, il
m'a pas répondu. Je pense qu'il est
débordé, hein. Mais ça m'intéresse.
Alors, je vais me permettre d'ouvrir une
parenthèse. Euh,
on a un ami qui est décédé fin 2019 qui
était Jacques Blamont qui était
fondateur du programme spatial français
qui a envoyé des ballons sur Vénus.
Et un jour, on discutait autour de cette
question et je lui ai dit "Mais comment
ça tit venu de d'envoyer des ballons sur
Vénus ?" Il m'a dit "Je l'ai rêvé et
ensuite j'ai travaillé pendant 18 ans
pour accomplir ce rêve et et je vous
remercie pour me permettre de de
raconter cette histoire."
J'ai connu Chel Bamont, il avait écrit
un très beau livre dont le titre ne me
revient pas.
Introduction au siècle des menaces.
Non, avant la sort du rêve
avant.
Euh je me rappelle plus je l'ai plus
mais j'avais eu une discussion avec lui
à à France Culture. [grognement] Ben
oui, je pense que Einstein c'est pareil
entre son idée et la théorie de la
réalité générale, il s'est passé 8 ans
de travail infernal parce que l'idée est
très simple, je l'ai expliqué mais la
form la formalisation de cette idée
mathématiquement ça été horrible parce
que parce que évidemment j'ai pris
l'exemple de ce micro là si je le lâche
il tombe comme moi. Si le micro était à
20 km de moi, il tomberait pas
parallèlement à moi. Moi, je tombe vers
le centre de la terre, lui aussi. Donc,
c'est pas parallèle. Et ça, ça crée une
complication mathématique qui qui a eu
du mal à résoudre. [grognement]
La sensation alors d'un pesanteur
et bien euh
ça m'a fait me poser une question.
D'abord, la sensation est très agréable,
vraiment agréable, mais elle est
indiscible parce que pour les raisons
que j'ai dit, on n'a pas le vocabulaire
pour dire ça. On parle de sérénité, de
bien-être.
Bon, il y a une forme de jouissance.
D'ailleurs, quand on s'est posé après ce
vol qui a duré 3 heures au total, tous
les gens avaient la banane. Il y a une
sorte de de je sais pas de de sérénité
qui est lié à l'impondérabilité.
C'est peut-être le fait que en fait tout
devient léger.
plus rien n'est grave parce que tout il
y a plus de poids. On a de la masse mais
elle est non pesante. Et donc
tout le vocabulaire dit traduit ça quand
on dit c'est grave, ça veut dire ça
pèse. Mais là ce qui est massif ne pèse
plus.
Donc je pense que ça
ça libère ça libère psychiquement de de
quelque chose
et
et je me demande si
euh euh bah qu'est-ce qu'on doit à la
gravitation et surtout
si on pouvait faire un expériment de
pensée qui serait celle-ci ? Dans quel
champ de gravitation
devrions-nous vivre pour que nos
sensations soient les plus agréables ?
C'est pas forcément la gravité
terrestre, c'est peut-être un peu moins,
peut-être un peu plus, je sais pas.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà essayé euh la
chambre de privation sensorielle ?
Non,
c'est une chambre où on vous met dans
une eau à la température corporelle,
donc vous êtes dans une pseudo à
pesanteur
sans bruit. C'est comme plonger dans un
cot.
Euh, il faudrait que vous essayiez ça un
jour.
Ouais,
mais ça rend pas fou ça fait
ça peut rendre fou. C'est c'est utilisé
comme technique de torture par la CIA
encore eux qui détournent tout un tas de
trucs pour
ça ça peut rendre fou
mais c'est c'est
ça me tente pas
ça
ça ne me tente pas pour cette raison
mais
à condition ça dure pas longtemps
la la plongée sous-marine vous avez déjà
essayé non pas à cause de vos oreilles
non
c'est c'est
mais vous savez le projet sous-marine
ça me ramène à Galilée hein
[grognement]
Galil Galilé avait un ami qui s'appelait
Baliani
et en 1630, il a écrit une lettre à
Galilée. Lettre incroyable. Il fait une
expérience de pensée. Il imagine qu'il
est au fond de la mer, qu'il a trouvé un
moyen de respirer qui ne détaille pas.
C'est une expérience de pensée, hein. Il
imagine qu'il pose une enfort sur sa
tête et il comprend que s'il était sous
l'eau, il ne sentirait pas sur sa tête
le poids de l'enfort.
Et donc alors que quand vous êtes dans
l'air sur la surface de la terre, vous
mettez une enfant sur la tête, vous
sentez le poids. Et ça ça c c c c cet
argument incroyable a aidé Galilée
à comprendre que le vide était possible,
que la nature n'a pas horreur du vide
mais qu'il existe en fait une pression
atmosphérique, ce qu'on appelait à
l'époque la pesanteur de l'air qui est
tellement intense que quand on fait le
vide dans une enceinte, le moindre
orifice fait que l'air rentre et qu'en
fait ça ça l'a amené, c'est une longue
histoire, je vais pas la raconter mais
ça l'a amené à complètement changer
La façon de comprendre ce qui se passe
quand on aspire du jus d'orange avec une
paille. Regardez, je imaginez expérience
de penser. J'ai un verre de jus
d'orange, une paille, j'aspire,
le liquide monte dans la paille. C'est
quand même incroyable, non ?
Ça veut dire que le la gravité qui
normalement maintient le liquide dans le
verre semble déjouer par le fait que
j'aspire dans la paille. explication
avantgalé.
Bah la nature or du vide. Donc si
j'aspire dans la paille, je vais créer
du vide dans la paille. la nature a hors
de ça et donc elle demande à toute la
matière qui est autour en l'occurrence
le jus d'ange de monter dans la paille
pour empêcher que le vide apparaisse.
Donc on pensait que l'horreur que la
nature a pour le vide agit comme un
antidépresseur.
Dès qu'il y a une dépression qui se
manifeste bah toute la matière est
mobilisée pour empêcher qu'elle
s'accentue. Voilà. Et en fait Galilée,
c'est une longue histoire qui qui est
liée aux fontaines qui existait dans la
ville de Florence.
D'illeurs une ville magnifique.
Voilà qui qui était magnifique qui était
le symbole de la Renaissance. Mais les
Fontin avaient vu que quand ils étaient
pompés l'eau du fleuve qui coulait à
Florence qui s'appelle l'Arnaud quand le
tube était d'une longueur supérieure à
18 coudés ce qui fait 10 m bah il avait
beau pompé avec toute la force qu'il
voulait l'eau ne montait plus au-delà de
10 m.
Et et Galilée apprend cela parce qu'il
ils ont écrit une lettre à Galilée et il
comprend qu'en fait le fait qu'il bloque
à 10 m, c'est la preuve que la nature
n'a pas horreur du vide mais qu'il
existe une pression atmosphérique
qui vaut 10 tonnes par mètre carré.
Et alors comment expliquer le jus
d'orange avec cette nouvelle explication
? Ben quand j'pire,
je diminue la pression dans la paille.
Il y a la pression de qui appuie sur le
liquide qui est dans le verre. Elle
appuie aussi sur le liquide qui est dans
la paille quand je n'aspire pas, mais
quand j'aspire, cette pression devient
plus faible. Donc c'est la pression qui
s'exerce du haut vers le bas qui fait
monter le liquide dans la paille.
Et ça c'est quand même un un événement
qui a coupé l'histoire en deux
puisqueavant on croyait que le vide ne
pouvait pas exister et là on comprend
qu'on peut faire le vide d'une façon qui
n'avait pas été envisagée auparavant. Je
vais je vais poser quelques questions à
l'innet parce que j' l'impression que ça
fait 10 minutes qu'on est ensemble mais
ça en fait ça fait 43 minutes.
43 minutes
et ouais on voit pas le temps passer.
Euh première question internet. Euh
quelle est votre dernière profonde
remise en question de votre perception
de la réalité ?
[soupir][souffle coupé]
Pas obligé de répondre hein.
Non si si je peux répondre. Elle est
ancienne hein, c'est la découverte de la
mécanique quantique. Euh donc c'est quel
âge j'avais ? J'ai j'ai expliqué que
j'avais été
formé par Bernard Espagia et c'est lui
qui m'a montré que la physique quantique
problématise
le rapport à la réalité au sens où quand
on fait une mesure sur un système, une
particule par exemple, bah ce n'est pas
une sténographie, c'estàd c'est pas un
enregistrement d'une propriété qui
existait telle qu'elle avant la mesure.
Le fait de faire la mesure modifie
l'état du système. Et donc on n pas
accès au réel lui-même, on a accès à
notre interaction avec lui. Ça c'était
un choc très violent dont je suis pas
remu et tous les petits chocs que j'ai
pu avoir après étaient négligeables par
rapport à celui-là.
Et une autre question que je vais
laisser poser par notre technicien
caméraman réalisateur Cerveau gauche.
Oui. Bah puisque tu es venu avec le
gilet avec les équations de Schringer,
est-ce que tu pourrais nous en dire plus
sur le la mécanique quantique et les un
peu les dernières nouveautés sur la
recherche ? Alors
euh moi je n'aime pas parler rapidement
euh de la physique quantique
mais je n'aime pas ne pas vous faire
plaisir. Donc je vais parler un peu
rapidement de la physique quantique.
Alors [raclement de gorge]
euh vous savez qu'en physique la
physique on apprend au lycée qu'on
appelle la physique classique distingue
deux sortes d'objets. Il y a les ondes a
les corpuscules.
Les ondes elles ont une propriété
singulière. Elles sont capables de
s'ajouter les unes aux autres si elles
sont de même type. Par exemple, si je
prends une onde électromagnétique,
une première, une deuxième onde
électromagnétique, ben je peux les
ajouter. Et l'amplitude de l'onde
résultante, c'est la somme des deux
amplitudes des deux ondes que j'ai
ajouté. Donc j'ajoute les amplitudes.
Donc je peux ajouter une onde à une
autre onde du même type. C'est ce qu'on
appelle le principe de superposition.
Euh et on voit bien que ça marche pas
pour les corpuscules.
Et l'idée fondamentale de la physique
quantique, c'est de dire on se fiche de
la nature des objets physiques qu'on
considère, que ce soit un électron, un
atome, une étoile, n'importe quoi
d'autre. On s'en fiche. On décide de
décrire les états physiques de ces
objets par des entités mathématiques A,
B, C, D, tout ce qu'on veut qui ont la
propriété de pouvoir s'ajouter les unes
aux autres comme si elles étaient des
ondes.
Donc le principe de base, c'est de dire
si je prends un électron,
il peut être par exemple dans l'état A,
l'état A c'est l'électron qui est là à
ma gauche ou bien dans l'état B, c'est
l'électron qui est là à ma droite. Mais
s'il peut être dans A ou dans B, alors
il peut aussi être mis dans l'état A +
B. J'ai ajouté les états. Et toute la
question c'est que veut dire A + B ?
Que veut dire A + B ? Alors, ce principe
de superposition,
il a permis entre autres choses à
Schroninger d'écrire son équation. Bon,
la question fondamentale de
l'interprétation, c'est que veut dire A
+ B ? Alors, ce que dit la mécanique
quanti antique qu'on appelle orthodoxe,
c'est de dire si vous avez un appareil
de mesure qui permet de détecter la
position de l'électron,
si l'électron est dans A + B,
alors en faisant la mesure, vous avez
une chance sur deux de le trouver dans A
et une chance sur de le trouver dans B.
Mais évidemment, si vous le trouvez dans
A,
vous allez vous aurez envie de
considérer qu'en fait avant que vous
fassiez la mesure, il était déjà dans A.
Et la physique quantique vous dit non,
il est dans A + B.
C'estàd que la mesure a changé A + B en
A. Et si vous l'aviez trouvé dans B, la
mesure aurait changé A + B en B. Donc la
mesure a changé l'état de l'électron.
Avant, il avait pas de position bien
définie. Après, il en a une qui est bien
définie, c'est soit A, soit B. C'est ce
qu'on appelle la réduction du paquet
d'ondes. Et après, quand on dit cela,
évidemment, il y a des esprits comme
Einstein qui disent "Mais c'est pas
possible ça, c'est pas possible. Si je
trouve A, c'est que c'était Avant. Ça
n'est pas ce que dit la mécanique
quantique. Donc la mécanique quantique
est incomplète. du manque des
informations sur l'état de l'électron
qui si nous les connaissions
nous permettrait de prédire à coup sûr
que c'est A qu'on va trouver ou bien que
c'est B si d'autres conditions sont
réunies. Et ça ça a déclenché un débat
absolument incroyable avec un autre
physicien qui s'appelle Nils Bor et
c'est un débat presque philosophique sur
ce qu'on doit attendre de la physique
mais qui a pu être tranché par une
expérience faite dans les années 1980
notamment à Horset par l'équipe d'Alain
Asper un physicien français qui a montré
que il y a pas de variable cachée
locale. Enfin ça devait un peu technique
mais la physique antique c'est vraiment
ça. C'est très compliqué à comprendre
mais d'un point de vue formel c'est très
simple puisque c'est basé sur la règle
universel de l'addition. Il y a pas plus
simple.
On va se téléporter sur une autre
question.
Monsieur Clint a-t-il un avis sur les
satellites privés et peut-être plus
particulièrement sur leurs impacts sur
l'avancée pour la science et l'impact
sur le développement futur de nos
sociétés ?
Un avis sur les satellites privés, je
savais pas que ça existait. C'est sp
Ah, c'est pas des satellites, c'est des
lanceurs.
Les constellations [raclement de gorge]
privées.
Ah oui, alors j'ai pas vraiment d'avis.
Euh
moi, je pense qu'aller dans l'espace
simplement pour faire du tourisme
euh ça me va pas. Voilà, ça ne me va
pas. Il y a beaucoup de débris dans
l'espace, c'est un autre problème mais
ça devient un danger pour les
astronautes qui sont en orbite autour de
la Terre. Donc je pense que l'espace
doit être un lieu
plutôt destiné à la recherche, à
l'observation. Alors militaire ou civil,
on sait que les deux choses se font mais
je préfère que ce soit une affaire
plutôt non privé. Oui, je suis pas très
enthousiaste de ça. D'autant que le
bilan carbone de certains de ces
lanceurs
n'est pas très bon. Mais comme j'ai fait
un vol 0 G, je me sens mal placé pour
faire la morale.
C'est de la recherche.
Question, je sais pas si vous allez
pouvoir y répondre. J'ai alors question
de Rome. J'ai entendu lors d'une de
nouveau vos conférences que la gravité
était en fait une accélération du
solpension.
Serait-il possible de reprendre sur ce
point ?
La la gravitation serait
la gravité. Alors, d'après ce qui nous
marque, que la gravité était en fait une
accélération du sol,
mon avis, il doit se tromper.
Je crois pas avoir dit ça.
Euh, je comprends d'ailleurs pas la
formule.
Non, j'ai moi j'ai j'ai dit c'est pas
original du tout, que la gravitation
pour Einstein n'est pas une force, c'est
une déformation de la géométrie de
l'espace-temps.
Alors, d'ailleurs, on peut expliquer ça.
On peut expliquer ça de 3 minutes pour
le coup. On peut le faire rapidement.
Vous avez appris à l'école le principe
d'inertie
qui dit un corps qui n'est soumis à
aucune force un mouvement rectiline
uniforme. Donc qui va en ligne droite à
vitesse constante. Moi, j'ai appris ça
en classe de seconde hein. C'est un des
trois principes fondamentaux de la
mécanique de Newton. Et d'ailleurs,
quand j'étais en classe à cette
époque-là, j'avais été très très étonné
par ce principe qui me paraissait
contreintuitif, en tout cas qui me
paraissait contradictoire avec
l'expérience que j'avais du mouvement.
J'allais au lycée à vélo et j'avais bien
noté que quand je cessais de pédaler,
mon vélo s'arrêtait et là, j'avais
l'impression que la professeur me disait
bah quand on ne [__] plus, il y a plus
de force sur le vélo et il continue
indéfiniment. Non, c'est pas du tout ce
que j'avais observé. Bon,
connaiss pas la friction et tout ça
voilà, je connaissais pas la résistance
de l'air et cetera.
J'ai fini par comprendre.
En tombant, j'entends pas
en tombant. Ah oui,
alors
au 19e siècle à la fin on comprend qu'il
y a de la gravitation partout hein dans
l'univers.
Même si on va très loin d'une étoile, il
y a encore du champ gravitationnel. Donc
où que vous soyez dans l'espace ou que
vous soyez dans l'espace, vous subissez
la gravitation. Un corps où qu'il soit
subit au moins une force qui est la
gravitation. Donc quand vous avez un
principe dont l'énoncé commence par un
corps qui n'est soumis à aucune force,
vous avez l'impression de faire de la
métaphysique dans une situation fictive
qui n'est actuelle en aucun point de
l'espace.
Et donc il y a deux façons de réagir.
Une façon commune qui consiste à dire
bah c'est quasi on accepte de bâtir la
physique sur du sable c'estàd sur un
principe métaphysique qui ne peut être
vérifié directement en aucune occasion
mais dont on teste la validité par les
implications observables qu'il a. Une
autre façon qui a été dite par un jeune
homme assez génial, toujours le même
qui s'appelle Albert Einstein, qui a dit
l'autre solution c'est de démontrer que
la gravitation n'est pas une force.
Et alors si c'est le cas, un corps qui
est soumis à la gravitation pourra être
dit comme n'étant pas soumis à une force
puisque la gravitation n'est pas une
force.
Et c'est ce qu'il a montré. La
gravitation fait que dans
l'espace-temps, dans l'espace, tous les
corps ont un mouvement inertiel,
subissent aucune force. Ils vont en
ligne droite. Sauf que l'espace-temps
étant courbé, les lignes droites dans
l'espace-temps sont curvilignes.
Question internet.
A-t-il déjà fait le vide ?
Qui ?
Vous ? Alors, c'est marrant ça comme
question parce que
j'ai cris un livre sur le vide qui
s'appelle Ce qui est sans être tout à
fait que j'ai dédié à ma voisine
qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle Aladine Lacroix,
aujourd'hui décédé malheureusement, une
vieille dame qui était une dame
extraordinaire avec qui j'avais des
discussions sur le pas de la porte ou
sur le trottoir. Je la voyais souvent et
un jour un jour elle m'a elle m'a elle a
dû me trouver un peu fatiguée
et elle m'a dit Étienne vous devriez
apprendre à faire le vide.
Et cette phrase m'a travaillé.
[grognement] Je me suis demandé
qu'est-ce que c'est que le vide ?
Et surtout associer le vide au verbe
faire.
Ça m'a paru bizarre. Faire c'est un
verbe d'action.
Il faut faire quelque chose et puis une
fois qu'on a commencé à faire quelque
chose, ce qu'on a à faire c'est le vide.
C'est en fait rien. Donc donc ça m'a
poussé à écrire ce livre sur le vide, à
montrer comment le vide n'a rien avec le
néant.
Le néant, c'est ce qui reste quand on a
tout enlevé. Donc quand on a tout
enlevé, il y a absolument plus rien.
Alors que le vide, c'est quelque chose
de particulier dont la division devient
circulaire. Le vide, c'est ce qui reste
quand on a tout enlevé, sauf le vide.
Et donc il y a autant de vides qu'il y a
de théories physiques qui disent ce qui
existe et parmi les choses qui existent,
lesquelles on peut retirer et lesquelles
on est obligé de garder quoi.
Question internet.
Selon vous, dans quelle direction se
dirige la science ? Quel serait son but
ultime vis-à-vis de la société ?
Bah [raclement de gorge] ça c'est une
question à laquelle en fait c'est la
société de répondre c'est la société de
décider du titre de compagnonnage
qu'elle veut faire avec notamment les
nouvelles technologies rendues possibles
par la science.
Donc la question
pendant très longtemps la science était
enchassée dans l'idée de progrès.
La science c'est le moteur du progrès.
Le mot progrès a disparu. On l'a
remplacé par le mot innovation. Et en
fait, on a compris une chose qui est
essentielle, c'est que la science
produit des connaissances évidemment qui
à mon avis ont de la valeur. C'est pour
ça qu'il faut les diffuser. Mais elle
produit aussi de l'incertitude.
C'est que la science ne nous dit pas
ce que nous devons faire des
possibilités qu'elle nous donne. Et donc
il faut en discuter. Le problème c'est
que c'est très difficile d'en discuter
parce qu'on observe une forme de
décorrélation entre la militance et la
compétence. les gens militants pour ou
contre ne sont pas forcément très
compétents et les gens qui sont
compétents et modérés en général
s'expriment peu. Et donc je pense que
les gens modérés doivent s'engager sans
modération pour que les débats aient
lieu au lieu que ce soit des
affrontements stériles avec des
positions assez radicales. Et je et et
donc moi je en réponse à la question je
je dirais la science ouvre le champ des
possibles. Elle ferme aussi des portes
hein. Elle nous dit il y a des choses
impossibles, mais elleouvre le champ des
possibles. Il y a des choses qu'elle
nous permet de faire. La question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on choisit ? Comment on
choisit ? Et selon quel critère ? C'est
un problème presque politique. Bah
c'est qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour un bon
débat ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut pour
pour un bon débat ? C'est quoi un bon
débat ?
Ah ben un débat c'est un débat qui
respecte l'étymologie du ver débattre.
Tout simple. Vous savez ce que ça veut
dire débattre ? Je vous écoute.
12e siècle, c'est un verbe qui désigne
ce qu'il faut faire pour ne pas se
battre.
Donc débattre,
c'est discuter. Discuter sans utiliser
d'arguments d'autorité. C'est donc
argumenter. C'est pratiquer ce que
Berkson aurait appelé une politesse de
l'esprit.
Ça peut prendre du temps, ça peut être
très ennuyeux un débat, un vrai débat.
Mais à la fin, on sait ce pourquoi on
est d'accord et ce sur quoi on n'est pas
d'accord. Et on se bat si je le Mais au
moins, on sait pourquoi on se bat. Et et
je pense que ce qu'on appelle le débat
aujourd'hui, c'est au contraire une
discussion très vive avec beaucoup de
d'invectives et cetera. Et donc
débattre, ça suppose qu'on accorde du
temps à à la discussion et aussi qu'on
comprenne qu'avoir un avis, c'est pas la
même chose que se forger un avis.
Moi j'ai l'impression que les gens qui
ont un avis tranché s'estiment dédoiné
de l'obligation
d'apprendre
à propos de ce sur quoi ils ont un avis
tranché. Par exemple, si je dis je suis
pour le nucléaire, j'ai pas besoin de
savoir ce que c'est que le nucléaire, je
je suis pour. Si je dis je suis contre
le nucléaire, j'ai pas besoin de savoir
ce que c'est. Donc le fait d'avoir un
avis me me permet d'ignorer le sujet
alors que ça devrait être l'inverse. Et
donc je pense que quand on décide de
débattre, on doit s'informer, apprendre,
questionner, interpeller les experts et
à la fin de ce travail qui est
chronophage qui est chronophage,
alors on est capable d'avoir un avis et
on est capable de l'étayer et on est
capable de le défendre.
La suite de la question de J.
Que pensez-vous du transhumanisme, de la
robotisation de l'industrie, de
l'apparition future des androïdes et de
la potentielle fin du travail suite à ça
?
Bah voilà, voilà une bonne question
politique, c'est quelle est la part de
nos décisions que nous déléguons aux
machines ? Quelle est la part de nos
activités que nous déléguons aux
machines ? Là, c'est ça c'est une
question fondamentale et je vois pas
qu'elle soit vraiment discutée dans les
débats qui commencent à propos de
l'élection présidentielle. Ça c'est une
vraie question. Quelle est la part qu'on
laisse à la robotisation et à
l'intelligence artificielle ? Voilà.
Est-ce que c'est pas un sujet à discuter
ensemble ? C'est pas à moi de dire ce
qu'il faut faire. D'accord ? Mais on
voit bien que des questions urgentes se
posent qui ont d'ailleurs été montré.
Alors, le numérique a plein de qualité,
hein. C'est pas à vous que je vais dire
le contraire. Même pendant le
confinement, on a été bien aidé par le
fait qu'on pouvait télétravailler,
rester en contact avec nos proches sans
risquer de les contaminer et sans
risquer d'être soi-même contaminé. on il
y a eu le téléenseignement, enfin on a
vu qu'il y avait des usages du numérique
qui sont précieux dans certaines
situations. Mais on a vu aussi des
choses qui demande qu'on s'y intéresse
de près. Par exemple, on voit bien que
le numérique fabrique une nouvelle
condition de l'individu contemporain.
Je veux dire par là que en quelques
clics, je peux fabriquer mon chez soi
idéologique. c'est une communauté
numérique qui rassemble des gens qui
pensent comme moi, qui s'intéressent aux
mêmes choses que moi, qui s'abreuvent
aux mêmes sources et des algorithmes
d'IA vont m'alimenter en articles vidéos
qui vont dans le sens de ce que je
pense. Alors, si vous lisez le livre de
Tokville de la démocratie en Amérique,
superbe livre, [grognement] il explique
que la grande menace pour la démocratie,
c'est la constitution de ce qu'il
appelle des petites sociétés. C'est pas
du tout les salons mondains où on
discute, on s'étripe, on change d'idée à
mesure que les discussions progressent.
Non, on est dans des petites sociétés
qui défendent des valeurs et qui les
défendent comme si elles étaient plus
importantes que les valeurs du contrat
social.
Et ces clanes comme il les appelle aussi
bah s'ignorent mutuellement et
conduisent à une balcanisation de la
République. Et donc on voit que ça se
passe un peu comme ça quand même. Et
donc la question c'est comment comment
maintenir
la vivacité républicaine
avec cette nouvelle façon de vivre
ensemble ou de ne pas vivre ensemble ?
En fait notre cerveau n'aime pas être
contredit. Ça a toujours été vrai hein.
Avant le numérique déjà les gens de
gauche ne lisaient pas le Figaro et les
gens de droite ne lisaient pas
Libération. Erreur.
Nous voulons et c'est une erreur. Nous
voulons que la lecture qui est faite du
monde ressemble à notre interprétation
initiale du monde. On veut pas être
contredit. Mais avec le numérique, il y
a tellement d'informations qui disent
tout et son contraire que notre cerveau,
il a tendance à choisir les informations
dont il aimerait qu'elles soit vraies,
même si elles sont fausses.
D'où d'où penser contre soi-même.
[grognement] Euh question internet.
Quels sont les espoirs de monsieur Clin
sur la recherche de la théorie du tout ?
Quelles sont les théories les plus
prometteuses ? Peut-il nous en parler ?
Alors moi je crois pas qu'on aura une
théorie du tout. Je pense que une
théorie du tout, ça dépend de quoi on
parle d'ailleurs. Est-ce qu'une théorie
du tout, ce serait une théorie de tout ?
Moi, je pense que ce serait pas du tout
une théorie. C'est-à-dire que euh
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait la tester
? Comment est-ce qu'on pourrait savoir
que c'est la bonne ?
Et et c'est une question très
intéressante parce que moi, j'ai écrit
des choses là-dessus il y a très
longtemps et j'ai un peu mûri.
C'est-à-dire, j'ai j'ai eu samedi
dernier une discussion avec Francis Wolf
qui est un philosophe euh professeur à
l'École normale supérieure
qui qui qui a fait cette remarque que je
trouve très profonde. Il dit finalement
la science elle étudie la réalité,
elle étudie le réel mais euh not notre
vie à nous euh elle se déroule dans un
monde commun. D'accord ? et et une
théorie du tout nous éclairerait
peut-être sur la réalité mais pas sur
notre monde commun. Par exemple, une
théorie du tout qui les quatre
interaction fondamentales, donc la
physique quantique et la réité générale,
nous dirait pas quel sera le résultat
des prochaines élections. Elle nous
dirait sans doute pas ce qu'est la
conscience. Elle nous dirait pas quel
est le statut des lois biologiques, par
exemple. Et donc je pense que on a trop
vendu la peau de l'ours avant de l'avoir
tué. D'ailleurs, vous avez remarqué dans
les années 2000, on parlait beaucoup de
la théorie du tout. Aujourd'hui, on en
parle beaucoup moins. La théorie des
cornes a montré des problèmes, a montré
qu'elle avait des problèmes. Euh et donc
on est euh on est dans une période où on
parle beaucoup plus de conjecture,
difficile à vérifier expérimentalement
parce qu'on a pas les données plutôt que
de d'une théorie du tout. C'est comme si
on on s'était éloigné du but si vous
voulez. On a compris qu'on en savait
moins que ce qu'on pensait.
Euh [grognement] question internet. Quel
est votre théorème mathématique préférée
?
Alors euh mon préféré au sens où il me
fascine, c'est le théorème de Gudle.
Voilà un théorème de Gudle qui dit
qui qui alors justement la question
qu'est-ce qu'il dit ?
Il a été trouvé par Good GOL juste avant
la deuxième guerre mondiale. C'est un
théorème qu'on appelle d'indécitabilité.
En fait, il a deux énoncés. Moi, quand
on me l'a enseigné, mon professeur nous
a dit le théorème de Gudle dit que toute
axiomatique basée sur l'arithmétique
contient des propositions indécidables.
Donc des propositions dont on ne peut
pas dire dans le cas dont on se trouve
si elles sont vraies ou fausses. Mais
aux États-Unis et d'ailleurs Gle
lui-même l'écrivait de cette personne.
Gle et Sherbach,
pardon,
c'est Gudle et Sh.
Ouais, c'est le même Gudle de de voilà.
Et aux États-Unis, on dit toute
axiomatique basée sur l'arithmétique
contient des propositions qui sont
vraies et indémontrables.
C'est pas la même chose. Vrai et
indémontrable, c'est pas la même chose
que indécidable. Indécidable, c'est que
la valeur de vérité n'est pas fixée.
Dans l'autre définition, elle est fixée
mais on la connaît pas. On peut pas la
démontrer. Et ça c'est pourquoi ça me
fascine ? parce que c'est un théorème
dont l'énoncé
dépend de la conception que vous avez
des mathématiques. Il y a eu dans les
années 80 un débat incroyable entre
Alain Cô, mathématicien français qui a
la médaill et le professeur du collège
de France de l'époque qui qui s'appelle
qui s'appelait Lichnerovitz.
il discute et et à un moment
euh euh
Lichnerovitz qui est un constructiviste
comme on dit à à l'incône une
proposition vraie et indémontrable. Je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire. Je ne sais
pas ce que ça veut dire. C'est une sorte
de contradiction dans le terme si c'est
vrai, c'est que je peux le démontrer. Et
lui fait une réponse incroyable. Il
prend l'analogie d'un tribunal. Vous
êtes dans un tribunal, vous jugez un
cas. et vous avez des pièces, vous êtes
des éléments de dossier qui vous
permettent de savoir que telle ou telle
chose s'est produite.
Mais évidemment, il peut y avoir des
choses vraies qui se sont produites dont
le tribunal n'a pas la trace.
Donc dans le cadre du tribunal,
certaines propositions qui sont vraies
sont indémontrables. Et donc ça veut
dire que dans cette argumentation d'Alin
Cône, il y a le tribunal mais il y a
aussi une extériorité au tribunal. Il y
a un ailleur dans lequel il y a des
choses qui sont produites. Pour un
constructiviste, il y a rien d'autre que
les éléments de dossier. Il y a que le
tribunal, il y a pas d'extérieur. Et
donc il va parler de proposition
indécida. Euh oui, indécidable. Alors
que si les platoniciens s pensent qu'il
y a un extérieur, alors il dira c'est
des propitions qui sont vraies et
indémontrable. Donc c'est assez
fascinant d'autant plus que la
démonstration, le type de démonstration
de Godle et l'invention d'un nouveau
type de démonstration en mathématiques.
Question d'internet. Qu'en est-il de son
savoir sur la conscience ? A-t-il lu
Gudle et Sherback de Douglas
of
Offeter ?
Et merci.
Oui, je l'ai lu il y a très longtemps,
un livre fascinant. Bah la conscience
euh est-ce qu'elle est réductible à
l'activité
cérébrale ? Et ben, j'en sais rien.
Voilà. Est-ce que la conscience
bénéficie d'une extraterritorialité
par rapport à la physiocochimie qui se
déroule dans le cerveau ou est-ce
qu'elle est déductible des processus
physicochimiques qui ont lieu dans le
cerveau ? J'en sais rien.
Question d'internet qui est un peu posée
d'une façon, on va dire, percutante
ou
différente. Depuis quand de depuis quand
la science est-elle l'apanage ?
L'apanage de la plebe déjà, est-ce qu'on
peut dire
de la plebe ?
Ouais.
Ben je sais pas. Est-ce que c'est vrai
ça ? Et qu'appelle-ton la plebe ?
Oui, onappelle pas la plebe ici.
Non, je sais pas ce que c'est que la
pleb
moi non plus.
Question plus physique. Monsieur Clin
pratique pratique-t-il toujours l'ultra
trail ? Si oui, quelle course c'est
quelle course de prévu ? Ah bah oui,
enfin je sais. Cet été, j'étais super
entraîné mais j'ai fait une course de
montagne sur le PE Bad en faisant un
rappel, je me suis tordu la cheville qui
m'a tordu le genou. J'ai été blessé,
j'ai pas pu faire la course et je vais
me réinscrire pour 2022 à la course de
l'UTMB qui s'appelle l'OCC.
Il nous reste deux trois questions. Je
vais je vais en prendre
une au hasard.
Quel est son avis sur la dite conquête
spatiale ? Est-ce qu'il y croit ?
La conquête spatiale, est-ce que j'y
crois ? Alors, est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est une conquête ? Moi, j'ai
l'impression que l'humanité va retourner
sur la Lune. Enfin, des humains vont
retourner sur la Lune, ça me semble à
peu près clair, y compris sur la face
cachée.
Mars,
c'est
compliqué
là, je crois que c'est d'énormes
problèmes et si j'essaie de faire
l'expérience de pensée correspondante,
je la trouve très très difficile. Il y a
réellement cosmique, il a les éruptions
solaires, il y a la durée du voyage, il
y a le fait qu'elle arrivé, il y a
personne pour nous attendre, il faut se
nourrir. Qu'est-ce qu'on mange même
pendant le voyage ?
Euh il faut rester sur la planète dont
la gravité pas n'est pas la même que sur
la Terre. Donc quel quels sont les
effets d'une gravité modifier sur le sur
le cœur, sur la psychée ? Moi, je vais
vous dire une chose. Euh je pense que
nous sommes des êtres géocentrés,
c'est-à-dire que nous sommes terriens
avant d'être humain et on peut aller
ailleurs sans doute, mais si on va
ailleurs, on sera plus humain. On sera
pas humain de la même façon. En tout
cas, même sur terre, si vous allez
passer 15 jours au sommet de l'Evrest
euh 15 jours, ouais
15 jours au sommet de l'évrest quand
vous redescendez, je suis pas sûr de
vous reconnaître.
Il Musk, il en pense quoi Étienne Clin
Musk ? Je le connais pas
moi. Je je ne le connais pas. Je l'ai
jamais rencontré.
Je vais pas émettre un avis sur une
personne que j'ai jamais rencontré.
Mais mais
je pense qu'il en ce que je perçois de
lui, de ce qu'il dit, c'est qu'il il
vend beaucoup de hype beaucoup
de hype, de discours très prometteur.
Alors, je sais bien que vous l'avez dit
vous-même, c'est le rêve qui est le
moteur de certaines actions, de certains
engagements. C'est le rêve qui est
parfois le moteur de la détermination.
On peut pas contester ça mais quand il
crois que c'est lui qui propose Mars
pour 2035,
c'est ça hein. Ça, j'y crois pas.
Question d'internet. Quel est votre
ressenti sur le futur de la société
humaine dans environ 5 siècles ? Plutôt
une espèce interplanétaire ou une espèce
éteinte ?
Bah, est-ce qu'il y a le choix ? Est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres choix ? [rires]
J'espère qu'il y a encore des humains.
Moi, je pense que on a compris quelque
chose de fondamental, c'est que ce qui
va se passer
va dépendre en partie de ce que nous
allons faire.
Ce qui va se passer va dépendre de ce
que nous allons faire. Comme nous ne
pouvons pas prévoir facilement ce que
nous allons faire, nous avons du mal à
prédire ce qui va se passer. Mais
j'espère qu'il y a une alternative entre
l'extinction ou le fait d'être ailleurs.
Moi, je je pense pas que l'humanité
pourra se déplacer ailleurs. Peut-être
que des échantillons d'humains pourront
partir.
J'ai un grand doute, mais l'humanité,
comme je l'ai dit, elle est terrestre où
elle n'est pas.
Est-ce qu'il y a des nouveautés dans la
recherche scientifique qui t'intéressent
particulièrement ? Les découvertes qu'on
peut faire en ce moment.
Ben disons que
moi je m'intéresse
à cette question de la matière noire.
Bon, ça fait longtemps qu'elle est
posée, hein. Vous savez quand il y a une
contradiction entre ce que dit une
théorie et ce qu'on observe, en
l'occurrence c'est le mouvement des
galaxies.
Euh on ne comprend avec la la théorie de
la gravitation le mouvement des galaxies
que si on suppose qu'il y a une masse
plus importante que celle qu'on voit que
celle qui envoie de la lumière.
Et donc il faut trouver de quoi est
faite cette matière dite noire, quelles
sont les particules qui la constituent.
Pour l'instant, on a des candidats mais
on n pas de preuve expérimental ou
observationnelle. une autre piste qui
dit mais peut-être qu'il y a pas de
matière noire et que ce sont les
équations qui nous disent qu'il doit y
en avoir une qui sont fausses. Donc on a
le choix entre une piste législative, il
faut changer la loi de la gravitation en
l'occurrence ou une piste ontologique.
Il faut imaginer qu'il y a des choses
qu'on ne connaît pas qu'on va découvrir.
C'est un débat qui n'est pas tranché et
j'espère vivre assez longtemps pour
connaître la bonne réponse.
Question internet. Quel sera le sujet du
prochain livre de monsieur clin ?
Ah,
je suis désolé, c'est pas trop le dire
ça. Alors, on entend
non, c'est je peux pas le dire mais il y
a un projet qui
pas mal. Question internet. Bonjour
monsieur Clain. Pensez-vous que
l'intrication quantique puisse avoir
lieu entre plusieurs dimensions ? Si
oui, cela pourrait-il résoudre les
problématiques de communication
FTL ?
Ah, c'est compliqué. Plusieurs
dimensions d'espace.
Ouais.
Plus non plusieurs dimensions.
On pose une autre question.
Alors ce qu'on voit bien enfin je suis
pas sûr de comprendre la question.
L'intrication quantique on sait faire on
sait l'observer
ça permet des tas de choses. La
téléportation non pas d'objets physique
mais d'état physique. Ça permet la
cryptographie quantique ça permettra
peut-être un jour l'ordinateur quantique
mais je crois pas que ce soit une
affaire de dimension. Alors j'ai mal
compris.
Euh question internet euh
on va la prendre au hasard pareil.
Pourquoi la Chine a-t-elle mobilisé un
budget colossal pour l'exploration
lunaire alors que me semble-t-il
cet astre a été vu et revu ?
Ben, j'en sais rien.
Faut leur demander.
C'est peut-être pour avoir une base.
Ouai. Ouai. Ouai ou peut-être exploiter
ou exploiter certaines
éléments qui s'y trouveraient. Question
internet. A-t-il un avis sur la fonte du
permafrost et sur la bombe climatique
qui qui en découle ?
Mais c'est drôle ces questions qui
commencent par est-ce que j'ai un avis ?
On les pose comme c'est écrit.
Ouais. Ouais, je comprends mais j'ai pas
d'avis. Moi je je sais que c'est un un
fait c'est un phénomène qui se déroule
et que la fonte du permafrost en effet
ça a des conséquences climatiques qu'on
peut calculer ou anticiper dis-moins.
Donc c'est inquiétant de même qui est
inquiétante la fonte progressive à
laquelle j'assiste chaque année de la
mer des glaces à Chamon de même qui est
inquiétante la fonte de la glace qui
maintient solidaire les unes aux autres
les blocs de granit qui font les
montagnes qu'on appelle les Alpes ou
d'autres et qui ont tendance à tomber.
Donc ça c'est une façon très directe de
voir les effets du changement
climatique.
Question internet. Est-ce que les
politiques sont des conquérants de
l'inutile ? comme les alpinistes.
Écoutez, moi je je vois pas très bien
comment je pourrait vous parler des
politiques en général. hein, je sais
qu'ils sont très décriés euh mais
imaginez une société dans laquelle il y
ait pas de politique.
Si on veut que il y a de la politique
avec un grand paix, il faut bien qu'il y
ait des gens, hommes ou femme, qui
fassent de la politique.
Donc on peut critiquer leur façon de
faire de la politique, mais on peut pas
critiquer le fait qu'il y ait de la
politique. Je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
est dans des temps où on a besoin de
politique
et donc
je crois pas qu'il soi les concurrents
de l'inutile. Non.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à nous
conseiller ?
Trois livres.
Alors si vous voulez rêver conseille
à boule pour point vous êtes un sauvage.
Changer [rires]
euh je dirais le mont analogue de René
Domal qui est un livre inachevé puisque
René Domal est mort. en 1943, si ma
mémoire est bonne pendant l'écriture de
ce roman qui est un livre qu'on peut
lire de 1000 façons différentes. À ma
connaissance, c'est le premier roman qui
prend au sérieux la relativité générale
dont on a parlé. C'est l'histoire d'une
montagne dont on ne voit pas le sommet
parce qu'elle est tellement massive
qu'elle a courbé l'espace dans ce
voisinage de sorte que la lumière venant
de son semaine ne peut pas nous
parvenir. Bon, il y a le cordé qui part
à la conquête de ce sommet qui
disparaît. C'est toute une histoire. Et
puis surtout, il y a il y a une idée que
je trouve magnifique. Il dit quelque
part que quand on escalade une montagne,
quand on atteint le sommet, on l'a fait
descendre. Tant que la montagne n'a pas
été conquise, elle appartient au domaine
des cieux et une fois qu'elle a été
conquise, elle devient terrestre. Donc
escalader une montagne, la gravir, c'est
la faire descendre.
Deuxème livre
euh
bah ce livre de Francis Wolfs dont je
parlais tout à l'heure qui s'appelle Le
monde à la première personne où il
établit une distinction entre ce qu'il
appelle le monde et ce qu'il appelle la
réalité.
Et puis en 3è livre
peut-être un livre de Clément Rosset qui
est mort il y a quel très peu il y a de
ou 3 ans, je crois, qui était un
personnage haut en couleur, un
philosophe que j'aimais beaucoup qui
[grognement] reprenait
à sa façon les idées de Parménid. Le
réel est un, on peut pas le diviser, on
peut pas le dédoubler par autre chose
que lui-même. Notamment son livre qui
s'appelle Le réel et son double que que
je trouve fascinant.
C'est le dernier film qui vous ait fait
vibrer, c'était quoi ?
J'ai du mal à trouver. C'est mauvais
signes. Euh,
j'ai aimé voir les illusions perdues.
Les illusions perdues, mais je dirais
pas que ça m'a fait vibrer, mais j'ai
trouvé fort, dynamique, respectueux du
roman. Ce que j'attends d'un d'une
adaptation d'un roman aussi célèbre que
celui de de Balzac.
Alors disons, il y a un film que je
revois souvent donc mais à chaque fois
il m'aime mais c'est l'armée des ombres.
L'armée des ombres, je le vois
régulièrement notamment parce que l'un
des personnages qui est joué par Paul
Meris
est la combinaison de Jean Moulin et de
Jean Cavaillè. cavill, grand
mathématicien, philosophe français qui
était fusi à race en 1944,
qui est à ma connaissance le seul
résistant
qui a fait de la prison, il s'est évadé,
euh qui est produit une œuvre
intellectuelle de grande envergure,
notamment sur les mathématiques. Il a
écrit des choses incroyables. Il est
mort à 40 ans, exécuté donc et c'est une
espèce de c'est un personnage qui me
fascine. Voilà.
et qui n'a pas dans la mémoire
collective laissé la trace qu'il
mériterait. Et donc je vais sans doute
écrire un peu sur lui parce qu'il est
une espèce de de troiture dans sa pensée
de logique. Il dit "Je suis devenu
résistant par logique. Par logique c'est
il y a même pas à discuter par logique.
Alors que les autres raisonnent il ratio
il trouvent des arguments pour les
Allemands sont là faut on est bien
obligé de enfin ils argumentent." lui
dit par logique non.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer.
Une bouteille à la mer pour les jeunes.
Instruisez-vous.
Ne ne ne participez pas à l'élaboration
d'une société de l'affecte.
Instruisez-vous et soyez courageux.
Étienne, merci.
Merci à vous.
[musique]